Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!
It's Jan here.
I really enjoyed Disney's new live-action
version of their animated classic The Jungle
Book, so, I wanted to look back over my top
five moments from the movie.
Before I kick off, I've got an awesome giveaway
from our friends at Genki Gear, so if you'd
like the chance to win a cool T-shirt like
the one I'm wearing from Genki Gear's new
limited release range, make sure you subscribe
and comment about your favourite moment from
the movie on this video.
For more details and ways to enter the comp,
check out the Gleam link in the video description
below!
Obviously, if you haven't seen The Jungle
Book yet, there's spoilers ahead!
But you can always watch my non-spoiler review
of the movie here.
Kicking off at number 5 is Mowgli's meeting
with King Louie.
The man-cub is kidnapped by a pack of monkeys
who take him to their leader, who's played
like a mob boss by actor Christopher Walken.
I love the fact that, at first, we only see
a little bit of King Louie as he talks to
Mowgli from the shadows.
It really makes the reveal of what an absolute
beast of an ape he is more effective.
This Gigantopithecus is desperate for Mowgli
to give him the secret of fire, or man's red
flower, as he calls it.
Cue a few verses of "I Wanna Be Like You",
before Baloo interrupts to try and rescue
Mowgli.
Baloo's over-the-top talk about how big a
fan he is of King Louie is really funny.
Then Mowgli makes a run for it, and Baloo
and Bagheera battle a bunch of monkeys, while
the King-Kong-like Louie chases the man-cub
through the stone temple, which soon comes
crashing down around him.
Pretty dramatic stuff!
At number 4 is the movie's big action-packed
finale!
When Bagheera confirms that Shere Khan has
killed Mowgli's adoptive wolf-father, Akela,
the man-cub runs off to the village where
he grabs a flaming torch before racing back
into the jungle, which he accidentally sets
on fire.
But the jungle fire is only one of Mowgli's
problems; Shere Khan's also ready to take
him down once and for all, but Mowgli's animal
friends step up and confront the terrifying
tiger in a series of clashes.
I like the fact that meanwhile Mowgli's following
Bagheera's advice and using his human skills
to set a trap to bring down Shere Khan.
And after the tiger chases Mowgli into the
blazing jungle and up a dead tree, it's not
long before Shere Khan exits this world the
same way many a Disney villain has bitten
the dust over the years: Hans Gruber-style!
And, I've gotta say, that I much prefer the
way this movie ends, with Mowgli staying in
the jungle with his friends and family, rather
than chasing after a girl as he does in the
1967 animated film.
I really love the movie's closing credits,
which make it in to my list at number 3.
They start off with The Jungle Book novel
jumping about, then it's flung open to reveal
the ruins of King Louie's temple.
The gigantic orangutan bursts out singing
"I Wanna Be Like You", which continues as
the pages of the book turn and we see the
animals including Bagheera, Baloo, and Shere
Khan pop up out of the pages in all their
photo-realistic glory.
Then they appear as beautiful hand-drawn-style
pictures alongside their voice actors' names,
and then it's back to photo-real creatures
including turtles crawling across the pages
of The Jungle Book.
And we also get to hear Scarlett Johansson's
hypnotic version of 'Trust In Me', Kaa's song
from the 1967 movie, which I really wish they'd
included in her part of the movie.
And there's also a cool version of Bare Necessities
by Dr John and the Nite Trippers.
The credits really are an absolute imaginative
delight.
At number 2 is Mowgli's first face-off with
Shere Khan.
Following the tiger's threats, Bagheera accompanies
the man-cub on his journey to leave the jungle.
Despite the initial quiet of the grassland
they're crossing, Bagheera warns Mowgli to
run to the ravine as he senses something's
not right.
Cue Shere Khan leaping out of the gently swaying
grass and tackling Bagheera before chasing
Mowgli through the field which is now full
of stampeding buffalo who race into the muddy
ravine where Mowgli is, hurtling towards our
favourite man-cub!
Shere Khan watches from above, at the edge
of the ravine, as Mowgli escapes by grabbing
on to the horns of one of the buffalo rushing
by him.
The scene's really fast-paced and immersive,
so much so that you can almost feel the mud
as it flies everywhere, including on to the
camera lens!
And at number 1 is Baloo's endless quest for
honey!
After the lazy-bones bear saves Mowgli from
Kaa, he sets the young human to work to pay
off his debt for being rescued by shimmying
up a huge rock face to collect honey from
the bee-hives at the top.
It's funny hearing Baloo assure Mowgli that
these particular bees don't sting.
And it's even funnier when our loveable liar's
joined by a bunch of other animals who comment
on how Mowgli's doing and we find out that
Baloo's tried this many times before with
many monkeys who all skedaddled as soon as
they were stung.
Oh, and when a huge piece of honey falls on
Fred the pygmy hog, it's so funny when Baloo
picks him up and licks the honey off his back!
Later, Mowgli makes himself a protective suit
of leaves and tools to do the job more efficiently,
while Baloo lies back, scratching his belly
until it's time to put into action Mowgli's
ingenious new honey-gathering technique.
Then Baloo goes back to a lazy day floating
down the river, singing Bare Necessities,
while Mowgli sits on his tum.
Ok, what are your favourite moments from The
Jungle Book?
And how do you think it compared to the original
animation?
I can't wait to hear from you in the comments
below!
If you enjoyed this video, you might want
to check out my other Jungle Book videos with
all the easter eggs and references in the
movie and also my full movie review.
Click either of the links here to check those
out!
And don't forget to subscribe and comment
on this video for a chance to win a cool Genki
Gear T-shirt!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!